I could talk about cookbooks all day.
Usually, I do actually.
(background giggles)
And that's why we created Cookbook Club.
And so far we've curated a roster of recommendations
from celebrity chefs, friends, people of note.
And now it's time for you to get involved.
That's actually why Pilar and I wanted
to create Cookbook club in the first place.
That's right.
This is Pilar Valdes, friend of the show.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Chef Pilar Valdez.
Yeah
And so we're gonna be joined by some VFF's today.
I'm really excited.
(Pilar laughing)
So without further ado, Pilar please tell us
what our Cookbook Club pick is today.
The "Essentials of Italian Classic Cooking"
by one of my culinary heroes, Marcella Hazan.
She is such, such a tremendous pioneer.
And I really think she taught people how
to approach Italian food in a whole different way.
And there were a few fundamentals
also that she really sort of drove home.
She emphasized the importance
of how to source really great ingredients
and then said at the end of the day
it all boils down to your palette, to your taste.
So learn and taste as you go.
Right, you know, that is something
that I think you have to really remember to do.
Absolutely.
Okay, well, I wanna bring in our VFFs.
I'm so excited.
Everybody, please welcome Lynn, Daniel, and Zenobia.
(crowd clapping)
Hi!
Oh my God look how many of us are here
I know
It's a real party.
Hi, Lynn, how are you?
I'm so good.
Thank you for having me as part of this cookbook club.
Well, how come you want it to be a part of it?
May I ask?
So I'm a busy mom of triplets
and I love to cook.
I usually reach for those simple recipes
that pack a lot of flavor
but I'm easily bored in the kitchen.
So I would love some new ideas
for different dishes that I can try.
Well, nothing better than Italian.
Okay. Daniel, I'm so glad you're here.
Hello!
Hello. I'm so happy to be here.
Thanks so much for having me.
Us too.
Why were you interested in Cookbook Club?
Well, cooking is my favorite hobby
and I have a collection of cookbooks.
I've always been drawn to cookbooks.
When I was a kid in elementary school
I would read the joy of cooking.
You were just talking like reading in bed.
I would read the joy of cooking in bed.
And I would think about recipes that I wanted to make.
And then the next day I would get up
and it'd be like, I don't feel good.
And so I would stay home from school
(laughter)
and everyone else will leave the house
and I would spend the entire day cooking.
And I did this several times.
So yeah.
(laughing)
Well that might be one of the most G-rated hooky
reasons I've ever heard of.
(laughing)
and a perfect reason that we're all together.
Now, Zenobia!
Hi Drew.
Have you recovered from the sushi
we had you eat here?
Yes I have, Oh my God.
(laughs)
We did never have I ever
and we made her eat her first sushi.
Zenobia props to you.
Yeah she spat it right out!
(Laughing)
I love it, you were so fun.
I'm so glad you're back.
May I ask, what interests you about cookbook club?
First of all, I am so happy to be back with you Drew.
And I just want to say that, you know, you got me
styling today because I love all of your outfits
your blouses.
So I said, let me step up my game today
with Drew with her blouse.
Thank you, Ladies and Gentlemen.
Alright, Lynn, what did you make
out of the book when you did sort of like a pre-run?
So I actually made
the baked filet of sole.
With tomatoes, oregano and hot pepper.
And that was really, really good too.
The fish I'd never cooked with that type of fish before.
And it had like a buttery nutty flavor
that really surprised me.
And it was still delicious.
My kids loved it.
The table section in the back
that she has in the book helped me
to figure out what to pair with the menu
to really deliver more than just that main course.
And I loved her book.
It's amazing.
You look really proud.
Like there's a glow in your face.
(laughing)
I know what I look like when I'm not proud
and I know what it looked like and you're, there's like
I hope you felt good about that.
I was really happy.
Daniel, what did you read,
learn or cook out of the book?
Oh, well, I like, I treated it like a regular book
and I just kept flipping.
And then I came across, crespelle
which are like little crepes
and you fill them with different things.
This recipe you filled them with spinach
and Prosciutto and Parmesan
and then you roll them up
and then you cover it with a creamy bechamel sauce
and Parmesan, cook it and Oh my God.
They're so, so delicious.
That's actually the first recipe
that I made out of this book ever as well so
No way.
(laughing)
That's so cool.
That's awesome.
Maybe it was like psychic manifestations
and by the way, gosh Daniel, that looks incredible.
It was incredible, I will make that again.
And Zenobia, What did you make?
I made the pork glazed with tomato and sage
and I definitely stepped up my pork chop.
[] Awesome.
My family absolutely loved it.
I'm glad it really worked out for you.
Thank you.
I have to say, this to me looks like
what I picture a cookbook to look like.
This is my very well-worn copy.
I know, like dog hair,
It's dog hair, it has pesto stains.
You'll probably find breadcrumbs in there.
(upbeat music)